I think people should stand as a council  fundamentally because they can make a  real difference to their community so as  a as a local Ward member I represent  five individual villagers and there are  some things that they're very easy to  overlook or ignore if you're a larger  sort of corporate body or entity but  it's things like fixing the roof of a  village hall helping with some speeding  issues on a particular stretch of road  it's a relatively minor things but in  terms of the quality of life for people  living there and that makes a real  difference so I think it's definitely  something I would recommend and  encourage others to do  foreign  [Music]